peu
[Musique]
rossi versailles a débloqué tmx l'aria
compte en mariant paix y est chanté en
allemand
[Musique]
mais c'est un homme bon soit il ya
toujours des broyeurs à turckheim pas
toujours mais ce soir il y en a tu peux
regarder
qu'est-ce que vous prenez pour vous
réchauffer vous vous sentez 1,19 alors
de la mûre faut pas trop ça va ça
réchauffe
que signifie en français la chanson vous
chanter écouter ce que je vais vous dire
la cloche a sonné teaser peu décevant de
rater de la chandelle
que dieu la vierge vous protège mais
voici deux cartes tuer vous tourner une
bonne nuit
il ya longtemps qu'il ya des veilleurs
de nuit et au caire
comme anticipé xiième siècle 11ème 12ème
siècle alors c'était les veilleurs de
nuit qui qui faisait rêver veilleur de
nuit comme pas comme pas comme moi
avaient alors ils faisaient leur ronde
toutes les heures à 10 heures 11 heures
à une heure du matin à 4 heures du matin
et pourquoi y avait-il des veilleurs de
nuit à l'origine il avait des veilleurs
de nuit
turckheim est une forteresse ya trois
déjà trois portes
les portes étaient fermées levé hier il
fait sa ronde pour ankara tandis pour ça
qu'ils disent prenez soin de l'art de la
gironde elle était un niveau feu que
vous disent les gens quand ils vous
voient dans la rue et va parfois ils
disent ils nous réveille les heures de
tig bras c'est une
c'est une vieille tradition qu'on a
qu'on a renouvelé mercredi
mais je voudrais bien tommy alors
ce vieux con il vient nous réveiller
c'est vous le matou faire à turckheim
comme vous les théories à peu près ça
combien de choses faites vous ont fait
fait ou fait pas les rues au fait le
faux soyons fous ramassent les ordures
n'est pas réparation des chemins
cantonniers tout monsieur meyer quel
sentiment éprouvez vous quand vous
faites votre ronde
enfin je le fais avec plaisir
il y a toujours des touristes qui qui
m'a tenté quand il ya des touristes vous
êtes fiers de poser pour les
photographes sur moi rêver avez vous
l'impression d'être une célébrité dans
leur région à une s'il est petit on se
dit c'est le dernier veilleurs de l'alt
alsace je ne sais pas si c'est vrai mais
quand j'ai entendu dire ses voeux
[Musique]
or